amongst people
who who have money
uh uh
you know you'll see that guys who have
real real money they will not use a
debit card
and not because they're not using a
debit card because they don't have the
cash they use the kind of a credit card
that you pay at the end of the month not
the kind of a credit card that you're
like hey you know i'm gonna you know
you pay off you know people have credit
cards that they pay at the end of the
month every month we have you know one
of our credit cards we pay i don't know
what the numbers every month four five
hundred thousand dollars per month that
we pay off because it's like a business
credit card but we have to pay it every
month it's not rolling right
and the reason for that is protection
because you don't want your debit card
number out there that's what you don't
want because that can be hacked into
your
cash where the money's at so that's the
only argument against
debit is to use credit that you pay at
the end of the month